my research is on computer security so
I'm going to talk today about some
applications of information theory in
encryption
so let's say that I build some sort of
fancy encryption scheme
I'm sure that you've seen the notation
for encryption so can you give me a
secret message
oh gosh 42 42. it's always 42.
so in computer file it's been covered
how we can write down encryption so
let's encrypt your number
42 with some key some secret key that
only you and I know so let's agree on
the number 20 as the key and what this
gives you is some big random looking
string
now I'm going to make some modification
here
um I'm going to translate this and say
we take the number 20 and we put it in
front of
so we compose it in front of whatever
the text is that you're sending me so
like append a text to it or something
like appended in front that's exactly
right concatenate the number 42 so that
means that this would become it happens
to be a number again the number
2042 but of course you could do this
with text instead of numbers as well
concatenation you just put it in front
right now why do we do this well the
reason we're doing this is because I
want my encryption to have a special
property which is that I want to be able
to kind of verify that I'm decrypting
the right thing and not accidentally
decrypting something else because this
number here corresponds to a large
random looking Cipher text
and so does this number they all
correspond to different random looking
ciphertexts but I can decrypt it with
any key I want and I will get some
outcome but I want to be able to verify
my outcome and see that I did the thing
I wanted to do so in this case when you
encrypt 20 followed by 43 f42 I can
decrypt it with the key 20.
and I get the number 2042 out and I can
verify that the first two characters are
my key
and I'm happy with that I take them off
and I keep the remainder if the
decryption had some other things in
front of it I wouldn't have been happy
and I would have said okay I've made a
mistake here so this is a form of
encryption where you can verify that
you've decrypted correctly and that it's
not nonsense
now why am I doing this well because
this shows you a weakness of information
Theory because I want to describe this
bit string here random looking bitstring
as having high entropy right that's what
it feels like it should have a high
entropy that's what it means to be
random looking but actually it's not
random at all right because if I look at
the decryption key 19 and I apply it to
that random looking bit string I'm
getting a ciphertext that will almost
certainly not start with 19. if I'm
decrypting it with 21 or the letter A or
you know whatever you can come up with
the odds are it's not going to start
with the right key which means that it's
not a valid decryption which means that
it's not in our set of possible
decryptions so there's only going to be
potentially one key that actually works
in other words there's only one
combination of key and ciphertext that
actually corresponds to this so that
means that the entropy of this string is
zero bits there's only one possible
string so applying information Theory
here says
there's only one thing it could mean but
that doesn't mean that you know what it
means and that's the interesting thing
about information Theory right it tells
you there's only one thing it can mean
but it doesn't tell you what that thing
is and the whole trick of encryption is
of this sort of encryption symmetric
encryption is not that there is multiple
combinations that they could be but
rather that is really really really
difficult to find the combination now in
the case of 20 and 42 it's maybe not
that difficult but if you use proper
keys and and messages that are properly
padded
then it's going to be insanely difficult
to fight the right combination so it's
not relying on there being multiple
combinations but rather there's only one
but it's increasingly difficult to find
but that raises a natural question can
we not have multiple combinations can we
not rely on this
and the answer is actually yes we can
so this is the idea behind a one-time
pad and what that is is you have some
binary message so 42 for example is 32
Plus 8 no 16 plus no four plus a 2 and
those one so I believe the binary
representation of 42 is 1 0 1 0 1 0 and
we then come up with a random binary pad
so let's say zero zero zero one zero
one and we xor these values meaning if
we have a one and a zero we get a one
if we get a zero and a zero we get a
zero
one one one
if the values are the same
you get a zero if the values are
different you get a one that's an xor so
you do that with your pad and you end up
with a binary string as long as we both
know the same pad we both get the same
string now the idea here is that any pad
is possible
so at for every string you get as output
there are
because this is one two three four five
six bits
exactly
uh 64 possible combinations in other
words there are six bits of entropy
so the one-time pad
does not rely on your problem being
computationally hard in fact your
combination your problem is
computationally super simple it doesn't
get easier than taking an xor of two
strings it really doesn't get much
easier than that but it relies on there
being
64 combinations that we could have done
it with which means that if I'm giving
you this string and you don't know the
pad there are exactly 64 pairs of pads
and messages that are in the set of
possibilities and every message is
represented exactly once for each pair
so that means that every message is
equally probable meaning you don't learn
anything about your message so this is
known as information theoretic security
Now the downside is that you're not
actually gaining anything in terms of
security because we had to have a secret
ahead of time that was six bits so 64
combinations
um
and afterwards we still have a secret of
exactly that size and I'm not able to
reuse this secret ever again because
once I do
we're not gaining any entropy so
we're stuck right so we have to have
some magic way uh to exchange renderness
and this by the way is what's being
proposed in some Quantum cryptography
schemes where you're communicating by
sharing a source of of Randomness so
that's all very interesting
um but that's a different type of
cryptography as the ones that you will
typically find in your computer
so if I get if I'm going to work you
know every day for the rest of my life
and I have these these choices
um then actually having the expected so
the average cost kind of makes sense
because I get to make this I get to
execute the time steps and we add based
on our schedule that amount of noise
right so we have but all of that